[Music]  rob kardashian is reminiscing about his  younger self on thursday the normally  reclusive reality star spoke out on  social media when a fan said they missed  him the Twitter user shared a throwback  gif of the now 30 year old holding his  nephew Mason and wrote I miss you so  much Rob Rob replied with a  heartbreaking response tweeting me too  with a heart emoji rob has remained  low-key since splitting from his ex and  mother of his child blac Chyna  he's only shared post spending quality  time with their daughter dreams so Rob  and Chyna have officially broken up but  they obviously still have to communicate  for the custody of dream since Rob and  Chyna's public blowout Kim and Khloe  discuss their brother's ongoing drama  with his ex on Keeping Up with the  Kardashians she's taunting him like love  makes you do tough things you think  anyone's proud of that no  [Music]